So for my diagram project, I decided to look at
the mobile version of reddit.com. And I started by opening
up the HTML. This is a cleaned up version. Everything
starts by requesting the HTML. When we receive, we immediately start
building and parsing the DOM. In the head of the
file, we find this CSS file, compact.css. So we fire off
a request for it and continue parsing the DOM. In
the next line down we find this script for Google Analytics
but it's marked async so it's not part of
the critical rendering path and we can ignore it
for this exercise. Here we've requesting jQuery, so we
fire off the request and block the parser. At this
point the preload scanner kicks in, which looks down
the HTML for other resources it can start downloading. It
finds reddit-init.js in the header, and it finds another
script, mobile.js in the body and immediately starts their downloads.
When the CSS arrives, we build the CSSOM,
which unblocks jQuery.js and reddit-init.js, which gets run right
here. Then, we continue building the DOM. We'll
then render the last job script file, mobile.js which
we can actually find down inside the body
of the script down here, which finally let's us
render the page. Looking at the metrics of
the page, this leaves us with five critical resources:
the HTML, the CSS file, and the three Java script files. To find the number
of critical bytes, we just need to add up the sizes of all of our
critical resources. Which gives us 99.6 kilobites.
And in the best case scenario, it's going to
take five round trips to collect all the files that we need for the site.